if anything
ever happens to me please know that the
31 terabytes of files i have are located
on hard drives in my condo
near 88th street and collins avenue just
north of miami beach
now that's june 8th 2021 right i went
and looked it up on twitter
there is no tweet with him saying that
so now go to the usa today story go back
and click on that story says fact check
no evidence john mcafee ever owned unit
and partially
collapsed florida condo which who cares
whether he owned it or rented it i'm not
worried about that what i'm worried
about is did he ever tweet that out
the claim john mcafee owned the union
partial collapse of condominium
building in florida conspiracy theorists
are attempting to connect the death of
antivirus entrepreneur john mackey to
florida high-rise building that
partially collapsed on june 24th
mcaveeney founded that june turns out
execution he was 75 is the next day
condominiums in surfside florida
collapse resulting in at least four
deaths and at least 150 people missing
the two events are unrelated but social
media users are there's a
nefarious connection john mcafee owned
the unit at the building that collapsed
the address of building 8777 collins
avenue south
reads a text message so that leads to ap
doing a story on it associated press
doing a story to respond to this
if ap does a story on this which let me
see which one it is it's page of four at
the bottom
here's what ap says claim the late john
mcafee the creator john mc anti-virus
unit in the condo building partially
collapsed thursday outside monterey
was located inside that's a claim ap's
assessment false mcafee was found dead
in his jail cell near barcelona on
wednesday didn't own the property at the
beachfront champlain
tower south condo in florida according
to the associate press review of public
records an image of the tweet and rich
mcafee claims
to own such a property is fabricated at
the close of a week
that includes the prison death of an
eccentric security software pioneer in
the collapse of a 12-story
oceanfront condominium tower near miami
social media users hatched false
conspiracy
conspiracy theories that bound the two
unrelated events together
and then they found out that there's a
they found out a note in his pocket and
his jail cell
yeah that read what did it read it said
the uh uh
uh there was a note in it you know which
one i'm talking about
where you know act and his suicidal
epstein yeah
so apparently they found a note and his
wife said there's no way in the world my
husband would commit suicide his last
words were
i love you babe i'll talk to you later
so she's like there's no way this
happens
so pat there's that word again that
we're starting to touch on a little bit
more and more and more
conspiracy theories yeah we're starting
to touch on this a little bit more and
something tells me with this guy mcafee
eccentric dude and all this stuff you
interviewed the guy i mean we spent
an hour talking about this guy let's not
watch the interview the interview in the
last uh a few days
has taken off it's been everywhere
everyone's messaging us
what was your thoughts about meeting
this guy look if the tweet is not up
there
you know june of 08 june of june 8th of
this year
easily you can make a fake tweet and put
it out there right
now some people are saying well what if
somebody on twitter went and deleted it
i don't know about that if it did
there'd be plenty of people with
screenshots who had it because to say
you know then there's some people that
are saying that 31 terabytes you should
have seen what's in it because if that
reveals itself
then kai said something very interesting
yesterday saying look
if if mcafee is who i think it is and
there's really a lot of credibility
behind what was in that 31 terabytes
do you really think he would only have
one copy of it in one place no no one
the way he would be he'd probably have
five ten of them
and would have him tell everybody where
it is
i don't know if you would tell everybody
where it is the point is he had some
information that people didn't want to
have
seen what that is in there some of us
will know some of us will never know
some of us are never going to know what
was in hillary clinton's clinton's
emails that was
you know some of us are not going to
know what was in biden's
laptop because he had fbi doesn't want
to investigate it but there's definitely
a little bit of thought of what was
really in that 31
terabytes that this guy had i'd be so
curious to know what was in it and i'm
willing to bet there are millions of
others
that want to know was it just a picture
it's a bunch of uh
you know random crazy files that he had
or is there anything there
that the world would want to know about
and if it's yes
maybe there is somebody who's a hacker
trying to really figure out what was in
there there's plenty of professional
hackers today that could find a lot of
different things
maybe someone's working on something
right now let me tell you this isn't the
end of the john mcafee conspiracy
theories that are going to run rampant i
don't think there's going to be a lot
more
uh i heard this i saw this but just to
be clear uh
there's no uh credibility to this story
no no no
the tweet is not out there actually um
my son dan just told me
snopes he looked up snopes as well yeah
i don't even look at snopes because
snopes to me
also has made a lot of mistakes
themselves of saying it's false but it
was
true if ap is coming out and saying
something about it
ap is typically you know they got not
that i mean look we're a customer of
them we like doing business with ap
but if ap saying something about it ap's
not even saying
the only thing that ap said is the fact
that he didn't own it so they want to
look at the record but they're not
saying
that that's a false claim they're just
saying conspiracy theories so
who knows what's going to come out i can
tell you like you said next week two
week three weeks i'm sure there's gonna
be more stuff that's gonna come out
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you